herzlich willkommen mein name ist
bastian venrath ich schreibe für die faz
über digitales und gaming und ich bin im
moment da wo alle gamer diese woche hin
wollen nämlich in köln auf der gamescom
diese messe wird vermarktet als die
heart of gaming das herz des gamings und
wenn man sich hier um guckt dann kann
man auf jeden fall zustimmen dass das
diese woche hier am rhein schlägt
370.000 leute waren letztes jahr hier
dieses jahr könnten durchaus noch ein
paar mehr werden
und wir haben uns für euch umgeguckt
gehen jetzt einmal rum und zeigen euch
wo es sich lohnt hinzugehen
[Musik]
halle 8 stand von bethesda die ist es
krass laut deshalb muss ich diesen weg
rum herrchen laden den mund halten die
tester zeigt hier erstes online und die
turner scholes bekam durch libyen durch
skyrim super rollenspiel jetzt rechts
online-version hier spielbar und
sumitomo naja die doom reihe ist bekannt
viel blut vieles blätter auch ihr spiel
war natürlich erwarten
aber ja kein shooter insofern halle 8
heiterte inhalten aller art ist der
große xbox stand wo man natürlich alle
möglichen spiele spielen kann die
ebenfalls dieses jahr mit implantaten
also hier gibt
und es gibt noch eine ganze menge
anderes zum zocken nächsten stand ganz
gut
[Musik]
eine halle weiter sitzt dann die
konkurrenz von xbox playstation
hier gibt es auch alle möglichen spiele
zu spielen es gibt hier rum so ganz
kleine spielecken wo immer so einst von
ferner stehen wo man deshalb auch ohne
längere warteschlangen denkmal dran
kommen kann
das remake von final fantasy 7 gibt es
hier
control ziemlich heißer geheimtipp
es geht um gedankenkontrolle mit denen
man gegenstände fliegen lassen kann im
prinzip auch ein shooter also denkmal
auch ein ziemlich guter tipp zu spielen
hier in halle 7
die leute die es gehen eher beschaulich
mögen und nicht unbedingt nicht
unterbrochen für die gibt es das
großartige fordere der wirtschaft zu
mindern
und da können sich einige hundert
einiger zeit spielen mit einem spiel was
im november neu kommen durchaus an die
vergangenheit erinnern denn versuche an
deren stand ich jetzt hier gerade sitze
erinnert sehr stark an das zu tag und
bis 2001 rauskam und ich schon eine
ganze weile her und habe dieses jahr
tatsächlich den gamescom preis für das
beste simulationsspiel gewonnen weil die
nicht müssen wir immer warten wollen
kann brennen zu fuß ihren stand in halle
7 auf der anderen seite der halle ein
bisschen fern vom playstation
oben gespielt werden und fans von so
tycoon oder auch generell von
wirtschaftssimulationen sollten hier auf
ihre kosten
[Musik]
in halle 6 geht es dann wieder ins
shooter-reihe die halt ubisoft sein
stand der doch relativ klein ist unser
letztes jahr wesentlich grösser klar
letztes jahr war es erst später dass sie
dabei heute jetzt er wieder so die
normalen spieler rangers exchange geht
es wieder darum dass man mit einem team
von spezialkräften terroristen verhaftet
oder anderweitig zur strecke bringen da
an spürbar
aber direkt nebenan ist wahrscheinlich
eines der spiele was dieses jahr so ein
bisschen der headliner sein könnte
cyberpunk 2077 ist ein bisschen mein
geheimtipp kommt auch erst später dieses
jahr kann hier angespielt werden achtung
der stand von cyber punk ist tatsächlich
relativ klein aber die schlange ist lang
also hier wird heute wahrscheinlich
richtig voll weil das spiel doch ein
bisschen als gehandelt wird
jamie greens dieses jahr gibt es
natürlich auch wieder ein neues feature
über 20 kann hier alle sechs gespielt
werden und ja man kann wieder mal
fußball spielen
man kann dann wieder einmal mit seinem
lieblingsverein siege einfahren und
pokale gewinnen aber man kann dieses
jahr das ist neu eben auch viel auf der
straße spielen die entwickler sagen für
die mehrheit der weltbevölkerung findet
fußball eben nicht im stadion statt
sondern auf der straße
insofern fußball fans kommen hier in
alles noch ihre kosten
[Musik]
ihr seht ein auto hinter mir dieses auto
ist hier in halle 6 ungefähr das
beliebte fotomotive das würde ich tun
kannst du jetzt zu urteilen sagt also
auto heißt um geht es um ein rennspiel
und zwar um need for speed das ist das
neue need for speed was dieses jahr noch
rauskommen hat das bekannteste rennserie
überhaupt in der gaming welt der erste
kam vor 25 jahren seit 1994 raus und in
need for speed geht es jetzt wieder mehr
um die illegalen straßenrennen also
nicht mehr so rennstrecke er so
boulevard verfolgungsjagd mit der
polizei und vor allem natürlich autos
und motten es gibt need for speed studio
das ist eine eigene smartphone app in
der ihr euch eure traumautos
zusammenrotten könnten sie dann ein
spiel zu verwenden also rennspiel fans
kommen hier bei need for speed auf ihre
kosten des standes und handeln 6
gegenüber von fifa 20 sofern kann man
direkt vom einen trotzdem an getränken
[Musik]
den neuen aller guten dinge sind drei
wir waren bei xbox live playstation 2
nintendo den händler natürlich vor allem
mit seiner switch konsole hier und
allerlei spiele wie darauf gespielt
werden können es gibt einen neuen zelda
es gibt die beiden neuen pokémon pokémon
schild und schwert und the witcher 3
meint haben und kommen auch für diese
dann in der opening night angekommen
insofern haben für den handy spielemarkt
ist hier ganz gut auf
dann gibt es hintermänner gibt es noch
den google spanier stand der ist ehrlich
augenblick wäre der rückzug konkurrenz
denkmal für die anderen etablierten
plattformen und ja also alle neun
durchaus auch eingang wert und
damit sind wir am änderung
von jan
ich will gamestop
[Musik]